politique à présent après les primaires
de la droite et du centre en novembre
dernier c'est au tour de celle de la
gauche et des écologistes ce jeudi soir
premier débat entre les sept prétendants
parmi eux benoît hamon depuis le début
du mois de décembre le député des
yvelines ne cesse de remonter dans les
sondages deux de ces propositions
devraient alimenter les échanges dans
quelques heures le revenu universel ou
encore la légalisation du cannabis le
scrutin va lui se dérouler lors des deux
dernier dimanche de janvier et nous
faisons le point sur le fonctionnement
le mode d'emploi de ce scrutin ce soir
c'est avec mélanie poquet alors cette
fois aussi wilfrid c'est une élection
ouverte tout le monde peut voter mais à
certaines conditions alors pour les
scrutins des 22 et 29 janvier il faut
être de nationalité française être
inscrit sur les listes électorales avant
le 31 décembre 2016 il faudra aussi
signer une charte autour des valeurs de
la gauche de la gauche et des
écologistes et une participation de 1
euro sera demandée pour chaque tour
alors le jour j vous devrez bien sûr à
voir avec vous une pièce d'identité une
carte un passeport ou tout document
prouvant votre identité si vous êtes
inscrits au cours de l'année 2016 sur
les listes électorales il faudra
présenter un justificatif d'inscription
alors il faut savoir que pourront aussi
voter ceux qui seront majeurs avant le
22 avril 2017 et les adhérents mineurs
de plus de 16 ans et les adhérents
étrangers des partis organisateurs alors
plus précisément dans les yvelines 120
bureaux de vote dans les seront ouverts
de 9 heures à 19 heures et plus de 700
militants et sympathisants sont
mobilisés encore plus précisément encore
cette fois sur saint quentin en yvelines
trois bureaux de vote seront ouverts par
exemple sur plaisir 4 à elancourt et 5 4
ap qui est la commune dans laquelle
benoît hamon a été conseiller municipal
jusqu'en janvier 2016 alors là je vous
écoute je vous propose d'écouter jean
claude husson c'est le président de
l'union des élus socialistes et
républicains des yvelines il nous
explique le but de ce scrutin
c'est surtout de choisir un projet est
de choisir le candidat qui sera tout
soutenu par tous les partis qui
soutiennent ces équipements il ya le
parti socialiste et le front démocrate
génération écologistes il ya l'union des
démocrates et écologistes et puis il ya
le parti radical de gauche donc tous ces
partis soutiendront le candidat qui sera
choisi à l'issue du deuxième tour alors
pour obtenir plus d'informations sur ces
primaires ou connaître tout simplement
le bureau de vote dans lequel vous
devrez vous rendre direction le site les
primaires citoyennes point fr